Batman V Superman's theatrical release
was two and a half hours long but we'll
be getting an extended r-rated cut with
the blu-ray and DVD release which Zack
Snyder has dubbed the ultimate Kurtz so
what didn't make it into the final movie
and what other unused concepts may we
see in future movies just before kicking
off I've got a fantastic giveaway from
our friends at Titan Books for the
official tech manual for Batman V
Superman dawn of Justice
inside this fab hardback book a tons of
amazing concept art an exclusive look at
Batman's Arsenal vehicles batsuits and
Batcave as well as Superman's Kryptonian
suit and Wonder Woman's iconic weaponry
for a chance to win subscribe and leave
a comment about the deleted scenes or
what you'd like to see in the extended
cut of Batman V Superman for more
details and ways to enter check out the
gleam link in the video description
below okay quick spoiler warning
obviously if you haven't seen Batman V
Superman yet I'll be discussing a ton of
spoilers so comeback as soon as you've
had a chance to see the movie first up
there was a much longer opening sequence
filmed with Lois Lane in the African
village Naomi that will be included in
the extended cut in the longest scene
the unnamed undercover CIA op who was
with Lois reveals himself as Daily
Planet photographer Jimmy Olsen and
tells Lois he's been assigned to her for
the mission director Zack Snyder had
originally hoped to cast Jesse Eisenberg
as Jimmy Olsen which he felt would
create a real WTF moment when the
character was killed right at the
beginning of the movie especially
because Eisenberg is a well-known actor
Snyder has defended his decision to kill
off the beloved DC character saying that
there wasn't room for Jimmy Olsen in the
current DC movie universe that Warner
Brothers is building jena malone fill
some scenes that we can Daphne look
forward to in the ultimate curse her
role is still unconformity isn't Robin
or Batgirl based on what we know so far
Malone is likely playing Oracle a
computer hacker in the comics who
provides tech support to a range of
superheroes in The Killing Joke graphic
novel The Joker's shop Barbara Gordon
paralyzing her which led her to become
Oracle another hint was this theory is
that in DC's TV universe when green
arrow was wondering what code names to
give Felicity Smoak
he said the Oracle was already taken
although the TV and film universe is a
separate it could be a cheeky little
hint that we'll be seeing Oracle on the
big screen
Dean was filmed in 2013 at East LA
college for a football game at Gotham
City University Stadium between the home
team and metropolis State University it
seems that this scene could be an
introduction to Vic stone aka cyborg
who's a football player in the comics
it's possible that some kind of tragedy
or terrible injury happened to Vic at
the football game which is why we see
him with missing arms and legs later
just before he's turned into cyborg by
the mother box at STAR Labs Armond green
the former running back from the Green
Bay Packers is credited in the film as
circa number two and he's confirmed to
be an extended Curt and may have
something to do with this scene the
supervillain metallo was originally
going to be the key villain in the Man
of Steel sequel in the comics metallo is
a cyborg who uses Kryptonite as his
power source and was created by the
scientist Emmet Vale who like Lex Luthor
in Batman V Superman was concerned about
Superman's power but when they decided
to make Batman V Superman rather than a
standalone Superman sequel the idea of
having metallo as a villain was put on
ice
however metallo creator Emmet Vale
played by actor Alf Lister did appear in
the movie working at the Lex Corp lab
leaving the path open for the villain to
appear in a future film Zack Snyder has
said that Batman villains the jokin
Riddler were almost put in Batman V
Superman however Snyder and screenwriter
Chris Terrio later felt their addition
would be a distraction for the main
protagonist Batman and Superman but the
super villains presence is still felt in
a number of Easter eggs that made their
way into the movie such as a Riddler and
Joker graffiti that litters the rundown
building where Batman and Superman fight
and the Joker graffiti all over the
deface Robin suit on the subject of dead
Robin his weapon which you see together
with his suit in the Batcave was
originally built as a fully intact piece
later Schneider decided that the weapon
needed to be shown broken as a further
hint and what happened to Robin at the
hands of the Joker by the way the
batwing was also designed with the
second seat which is where Robin would
have sat before he was killed ten years
before the events of Batman V Superman
since that happened Bruce Wayne has
modified the empty space to use it as
convenient storage for an extra set of
guns the fat wing was designed to have
folding wings so that when it's in the
Batcave and covered with a tarp it looks
and hangs just like a bat the batwing
did of course appear in the theatrical
release but we didn't get to see the
folding wings also production designer
Patrick Tatopoulos
said it was crucial that Batman had the
ability to take off and land anywhere
even in an alley so the designers also
made sure the batwing had the ability to
take off vertically and they even ran a
CG test to prove that the batwing could
do just that even though this didn't
happen in the final film
henry cavill was spotted filming scenes
outside the Gotham City Jail and
producer Deborah Snyder has confirmed
that scenes were clock Kent visits
Gotham to look into Batman's activities
more closely will appear in the extended
Curt bodybuilder Ct Fletcher has
confirmed he was on set for a prison
scene so it looks like we'll get to see
more details about Clark Kent's
investigation into some of the bat
vigilantes victims Dan employer who
starred in the TV comedy younger who
said he was on the set of Batman V
Superman right at the beginning of
shooting and that he played a character
called lieutenant Christine on IMDB he's
credited as drone pilot and has been
rumored he could end up as one of the
Green Lanterns
it remains to be seen whether what he
filmed makes it into the extended curse
and whether we'll get a tease for Green
Lantern in Batman V Superman or we'll
have to wait for the first Justice
League movie just after the opening
weekend for Batman V Superman Warner
Brothers released an intriguing deleted
scene titled communion in it we see a
SWAT team to send into the Kryptonian
Scout ship where they find Lex Luthor
communing with the demonic-looking
creature the creature feels like it
might hail from dark sides planet
apocalypse and it's look best matches
dark sighs Father Yuga Khan
other alternatives could be Steppenwolf
one of Darkseid's generals or even
possibly the DCE used version of
Darkseid himself
Darkseid was already teased in the main
theatrical release via the amiga symbols
at Bruce Wayne season his nightmare in
this deleted scene there are also three
mother boxes and an orb floating above
the demonic creature and they all
dissolve away as a soldiers reach legs
it looks like Lex is learning about
Darkseid in his forces via holographic
images the moment calls back to when
Clark Kent returned to the Scout ship in
Man of Steel and learned about Krypton
in the universe with his father jor-el
this deleted scene helps to tie up the
Easter eggs with theatrical release like
Lex Luthor's mention of Gods spawning
from the sky when talking about the
painting in his study and the
ding-ding-ding he says at the end of the
film which references the pink sound
that mother boxes make in the comics so
guys what do you think about the deleted
scenes do you think they would have made
the movie better or if they
made it more complicated as always I'd
love to hear what you've got to say in
the comments below and don't forget to
comment and subscribe for your chance to
win this awesome official hardback book
the tech manual for Batman V Superman
dawn of Justice for more details and
ways to enter check out the gleam link
in the video description below if you
enjoyed this video you might like to
explore the movie further with my guide
to all the Easter eggs and references in
the movie and very shortly I'll have a
couple of videos up on some cool facts
about the making of Batman V Superman
and also a special Wonder Woman video
you can click on any of the links right
here to check those out thanks for
watching yippee-ki-yay movie lovers